[Music]
PewDiePie literature Doki Doki welcome
back everybody to Perry pacefoot club
that's right who doesn't want to know
about what I think about books please
keep watching did you do your homework
this month that's right we have homework
on the PewDiePie channel now isn't that
exciting that's just what everyone wants
more of please keep watching please keep
what I've been reading a lot of great
comment from last month saying that you
got into reading because of the videos
that we've been doing and that's
essentially the goal of these videos is
to get you part of part of this book
club that we're doing now last month the
books that we read was the old man in
the sea Moby Dick man's search for
meaning and tonita Kotani
I couldn't find Toni tacky taani for
some reason it's 600 pounds on Amazon
I'm so sorry if you spent that money
this month I made sure that all the
books that I picked are actually
accessible my apologies okay I didn't do
my homework all of it but I bet you
didn't either and if you did I am so
sorry I also let red flowers for
algernon recommended by Brad really good
sound of waves the Temple of the golden
pavilion Bushido the soul of Japan the
book of five rings metamorphosis by
Franz Kafka and I think that was it
they're very short books that I read
this month and I think I made a mistake
of reading too many short books because
next month I'm gonna want to read some
longer novels instead of just novellas
it just sort of happened I just pick a
book I want to read and then I don't
really look to much on how long it is
anyway let's get into this the Old Man
and the sea by Ernst Hemingway you know
by this book everyone knows about this
book this is the quintessential teacher
wants you to read in in school kind of
book it which is actually why I picked
it as well because I want I want you to
be part of this did you read it what did
you think the story is of Santiago this
sailor he's very old and he's been
unlucky for a very long time he hasn't
caught any fish he
young apprentice the boy as he calls him
and he's not even allowed to sail with
Santiago anymore because of his parents
doesn't want him to he wants him to sail
with something that actually catches
some damn fish it takes place out of the
coast of Mexico I think or Cuba
Santiago sets out to break this unlucky
spree that he's on and he finally
catches something on his hook he doesn't
know what it is or how big it is but he
knows it's big and he pulls him away
from shore and he decides very early
that he's going to commit to try and
catch this fish no matter what it's a
very short book is very simple to read
you had the pinnacle of a minimalistic
approach to writing one character
essentially in such a simple setting as
the ocean I think aren't even called it
himself he coined it iceberg Theory
where you can probably guess what that
means I'm guessing as well that he's
giving us the tip of the iceberg and
it's up to us to interpret the rest what
does the fish mean why does he dream of
lions I really enjoyed it I thought it
was fun to read and and what kept me
through it was just is he going to catch
the damn fish fish or not I don't know
if I really think there's that much to
analyze personally but I'm sure there is
hey I just not that interested to be
honest I don't I didn't find it that
interesting especially after reading
Moby Dick as well which we'll get into
later there is a theme about masculinity
I think but that you have to catch this
fish no matter what that's there's a
certain manliness attached to that I
talked about this book briefly with my
mom and she said she actually really
really didn't like it and I wonder if it
is because of the whole masculinity
involved with it I enjoyed it it was it
was alright but the more I think about
it the less I enjoy it to be honest this
whole iceberg Theory thing just kind of
annoys me the more I think about it it's
there even an iceberg underneath the tip
Hemingway ha
moving on to Moby Dick Moby Dick is the
story we all know about Moby Dick what I
actually didn't know is that Moby Dick
is was a real whale that actually
existed in the 1800's it was called maka
dick and Herman Neville who wrote the
story was a whale's men as well or
seamen
and if book like Moby Dick just wouldn't
exist unless that was the case this Moby
Dick is the heart of a whale's men in
itself it really covers every single
aspect of whaling and by every single
aspect of whaling I mean every single
aspect but we'll get into that first of
all you know you probably know this
story anyway it follows the narrative of
Ismail who is this good-natured
Christian who wants to join a whaling
voyage so he travels and he stumbles
upon the other character which is
Queequeg which is a harpooneer who has
face tattoos he's a cannibal complete
opposite of Ismail but they become best
they become close friends anyway and
they have to share a bed together in the
early chapters and I remember reading it
thinking wow this is so silly and it's
so funny and so easy to follow I read a
lot of comments saying dude are you
actually gonna read Moby Dick that's a
pretty tough stuff and of course I'm
naive as always thinking wow this is so
easy to follow what are people talking
about they must not be as smart as I am
little did I know the chapters variates
a lot the book changes style of writing
you could say a lot it goes from
narrative to straight-up facts about
whales for example to poetry to
philosophy and it's surprisingly lack of
narrative in this book you think the
story of Moby Dick is so famous with a
Captain Ahab the the captain that wants
to capture this white whale no matter
what to the bitter end because he seeks
to revenge upon Moby Dick for taking
away his leg literally inside Moby Dick
there is the book of whales inside a
which is very different from this
minimalist book you have a book with
books inside it and if you are not
interested in whales I definitely don't
recommend reading this book it basically
covers every single aspect of whaling
let me tell you about the economy and
the ecology and the anatomy and the
philosophy and the poetry and the the
weight and the scale and the whales of
whales and the whales of everything
there is about whales is basically
covered in this book
if you're not ready for that and yeah I
don't know but there are parts that
really truly shine I almost want to just
read a passage from it but I don't think
we're on that level of crinch yet but
I'll tell you what when I finished
reading the book and I was flipping
through the pages the first line which
is a very famous line
call me Ismail maybe you don't
understand why it's it's a it's hard to
explain why that carries such an
emotional response reading that line but
it really does and for anyone that's
read the novel knows what I'm talking
about
it's obviously a book filled with
symbolism the the whole expression with
a white whale is a saying on itself
Herman really tries to deliver something
real he just doesn't just give us the
tip of the iceberg he gives us the whole
thing and there's something honorable
and that you can really appreciate about
that and I think Moby Dick I probably to
be honest I'm probably not really ready
for it yet but I'm really glad I read it
look forward to read it again at some
point in the future the third book that
we read I am so glad that I picked I
think this book is incredibly important
I didn't know I just picked it randomly
because I wanted to read something about
philosophy it's mine search for meaning
by dr. Viktor Frankl was so special
about this book is that Franco is an
Auschwitz concentration camp survivor
and he's a psychiatrist so he can then
answer the question what went through
the minds of people that survived these
concentration camps and I really want to
discuss this book with people and
whenever I did I just I was just met
with boredom because no one wants to
hear about the Holocaust people are
tired of hearing about the Holocaust we
know it's bad okay how often are we
gonna get a piece of literature that
really puts to test almost you can say
it's almost like Viktor treats himself
as a lab rat that's of not appropriate
expression but I think it's the best way
to explain it he discusses a lot for
example the quote from Nietzsche he who
has a why to live can bear almost any
how and Viktor really puts this to the
test because put it this way the whole
phrase what's the meaning of life is
asked to death but Viktor Frankl
actually does a really great job at
trying to answer that question
and I I couldn't help but agree with a
lot of it I also thought that it was
really great how this book was
originally written in without an
author's name in my in mind it was
published anonymously originally I feel
like this book is is a great tool to
just help people and especially maybe
I'm over generalizing here but I feel
like a lot of Millennials are struggling
to find meaning I certainly feel better
equipped for in case I know that sounds
a bit weird to say but in case something
really bad happens I feel like from
reading this book I am better equipped
to know how to handle it
that's a bit naive to say but I really
think there's some important stuff in
here and it's hard for me to explain
clearly the next book is much easier to
talk about it's recommended by Brad
flowers by Algernon Thank You Brad great
recommendation really enjoy this one
after reading Moby Dick I wanted
something easier to follow it follows
the story of Charlie Gordon who has an
IQ of 68 he lives a happy life and he
works at a bakery and he enjoys his time
around his friends but he knows he's not
very smart he knows he's stupid he wants
to become smarter more than anything and
we basically follow his progress reports
through the book that he rides he's
instructed to write because he's on
going this experiment that will actually
make him successively more and more
intelligent and we follow him realizing
that things that used to be positive
such as people that he thought were his
friends were actually just making fun of
him and he has to quickly find himself
growing up in a very short period of
time you can't help but sympathize for
Charlie it's a very tragic sad story it
was say it was really fun to read from
start to finish however and I really
really enjoyed it it was great
recommendation Thank You Brad
appreciate it the metamorphosis with
Franz Kafka is one I read it's so quick
I almost kind of feel like I should just
discuss it next month but I'm going to
talk about it anyway to me the idea of
turning into in an insect this is the
most disgusting idea ever and it just
freaks me out
I remember in the movie district 9 the
main character sort of becomes his alien
weird insect-like thing and it freaks me
out
funnily enough though friends Kefka
explicitly didn't want the cockroach to
be on the cover because once you read
the book the novella you really
understand it's not about the cockroach
a source McGregor who one day wakes up
and find himself that he's turned into a
giant cockroach and the first thing that
goes through his mind is funnily enough
how am I going to get to work
yeah Gregor has been supporting his
family by financially by working and he
doesn't really enjoy his job he knows he
wants to quit it but he's not able to do
with quite yet but now he finds himself
that he's a cockroach and we follow how
the family tries to deal with that they
try and lock him in they want to help
Gregor but they don't really know how
and they sort of keep keep him a secret
for other people they don't want other
people to find out about this obviously
it's really just a story about isolation
and feeling not wanted and feeling like
you're a problem it's such an awful
feeling anyone that's felt like that can
can sympathize with Gregor and feeling
like an actual cockroach and that's at
least why I think he chose a cockroach
while writing this it's a very sad story
far up following and I can't help but
sympathise with Gregor and reading about
Franz Kafka's life as well afterwards I
sort of understand more and more that
this is very personal story he had
issues with his father Franz Kafka
burned 90% of his work as well they
didn't even want anyone to read it which
I also can then understand because it's
clearly very personally drawn and
whenever I do stuff that's very personal
on YouTube by I want to delete it
afterwards cuz I don't want other people
sharing I don't know if that's the case
or why he did it but I can at least
relate to it in that sense yeah it's a
sad story I don't want to hear and tell
me I'm getting emotion just talking
about it it's kind of a novel that's
it's open for interpretation a lot of
people discuss is the father the bad
figure or is it the sister who's the bad
one and that
yeah whatever you think I don't know
read it it's good discovering this
author has been one of the most fun
discoveries I had in a very long time
I am so intrigued by this author Yukio
Mishima I wanted to read more Japanese
literature because I really like
Murakami so I randomly picked Yukio
Mishima is the sailor who fell from
grace from the sea and I was so and
what's the right word entranced by it I
felt so lost reading this book and in
the best possible way and I absolutely
loved it it follows a story of a young
boy who's sort of having adolescent mind
nabarro is a very young boy but he
hasn't like I said an adolescent mind he
lives in a seaside town of Yokohama
which is I think south of Tokyo it
doesn't matter I don't know why I said
that he's secretly part of this strange
gang it's sort of like a thought gang is
the best way to describe it they they
completely reject conventional ideas and
more they have their own set of morals
it's just so interesting it was like
anything I've ever read and I really
really enjoy that because of how
different it was and how strange he was
it's not like I agreed with everything
but I just was intrigued hearing about
it
nabarro meets with the Sailor called Ryu
G and he sees Ryu Jin an extreme high
regard he's as a pristine figure because
he's the pinnacle of manliness
essentially he's a man that committed
his whole life to the sea he's
deliberately chose not to settle down
with a wife and he goes on all these
adventures and nabarro just looks up to
this sailor but then real G meets with
Navarro's mom who is a widow and works
in a shop and they connect and
eventually they want to settle down with
each other so Ryoji wants to settle down
and become a husband essentially even
though it was against his principles and
nabarro obviously he has a problem with
this because in not just because it's
his mom that's involved but because in
his thought gang they look at fatherhood
as one of
worse things possible is to be a father
and he wants to protect this pristine
image that he has a Ryoji nabarro and
his thought gang decides I don't know
why I keep calling a thought gang it's
just a gang but and they decide what
they're gonna do about it and that's all
I'm gonna say it was really fun reading
a story that was so interesting and then
obviously the symbolism with all the
characters two cultures meeting you have
Ryu G who's that the pinnacle of
manliness he represents honor and oh I
think old old Japan the wife that that
represents the post-war culture and then
you have Navarro that wants to get keep
and protect the culture because there
was a giant cultural shift after the
World War two and that's a big theme for
Yukio Mishima was work which I learned
afterwards right after reading the the
sailor who fell from grace with the sea
I loved it so much and I wanted more
because it was so short I read the
temple of the golden pavilion and I
absolutely loved eight I feel like I
want to do a video just exclusively at
some point about Yukio Mishima once I
read more of his work because I'm so
fascinated by him his whole life is a
story and of itself and that sort of
strangely merged with all his novels
it's just so interesting I don't know if
you're interested in reading the book
just read the book first I would say cuz
for me the discovery of this author was
just so much fun and I don't want to
take that away from anyone I also read
sound of waves I don't really have too
much to say about it but I think I
should move on from Mishima for now and
then maybe we'll discuss it more in the
future after I read the book of five
rings I feel like such a kid when it
comes to this book I just can't help
myself
this is like the coolest book ever I
know I know
it's the kind of book people think very
seriously and they want to they want to
really analyze and give it a lot of
thought to to the words
but I just I feel like such a child with
this book anyway it's about Japan's
greatest warrior
it's an undefeated warrior who's passing
along his knowledge that of what he's
learned his master of strategy I think
he calls her something like that it's a
real work it's not a it's not fiction or
who knows I mean it was written
literally hundreds of years ago so I
don't know if any of it has been
confirmed or not but it's still how cool
is that you have an undefeated warrior
who's just explaining how he became
undefeated how cool is that
the book contains the book of fire the
book of water wind earth and void it
discusses that how his strategy is
scalable and if you master his strategy
if you can defeat one foe you can defeat
any number of foes and essentially
become invincible the pinnacle of zero
deaths everyone he has this sort of
nonsense approach to fighting where no
flier involved you should really just
focus on cutting down your enemy that's
the number one thing he talks about the
fact that he instead of holding that
katana traditionally people hold it with
two hands he holds it with one hand
which is harder but if you can master it
it's very beneficial but and then he
holds in this other hand the walky sake
how cool is that I've been joined just
keeping this in my pocket and reading a
passage every once in a while and just
thinking about it I'd be lying if I said
I understand anything that is in this
book to apply stickiness whether enemy
attacks and you also attack with the
longsword you should go in with a sticky
feeling and fix your longsword against
the enemies as you receive his cut the
spirit of stickiness is not hitting very
strongly but hitting so that the
longsword do not separate easily it is
best to approach as calmly as possible
when hitting the enemy's longsword with
stickiness the difference between
stickiness and entanglement is that
stickiness is firm an entanglement is
weak you must appreciate this
obviously there's a lot to learn from
this book and people still use the
teaching for other fields of profession
today obviously you don't have to be a
samurai to in today's society but people
use it in business for example and using
his strategy in business I just love how
this book exists I think it's fantastic
last but not least I read I was so
fascinated by the whole samurai and I
wanted to learn more about samurais all
right Bushido the soul of Japan for
anyone that wants to learn more about
Japanese culture and the history of it I
think Bushido is a great starting point
it's the book is called Bushido the soul
of Japan for a reason because the code
of ethics of the samurai has left such a
huge impact Japanese society and culture
even still today the explaining why
politeness is so important in Japanese
culture and the logic behind the
politeness as well what's really
interesting to know about think this is
a great book if you want to learn about
self control control their self impulses
but the chapters that I enjoy the most
was grimly enough about seppuku I'm sure
you've heard about seppuku before but in
case you don't know it's the act of
committing suicide or execution it's
sort of a mix in between but the the
samurai valued honor more than anything
honor was more valuable than life itself
and if a samurai messed up in a way made
a bad choice or the punishment would be
seppuku but it will also be a way for
them to restore their honor going down
on your knees and cutting your guts open
with a short sword and there's a
specific reason why the guts is chose
for it and and then someone would cut
off your head right afterwards
the reason why they did do this was to
restore honor and they honor meant more
to them than anything and their approach
the samurai approach to death I find so
interesting instead of trying to fight
it they see it as an opportunity I don't
know I thought it was very fascinating
to learn about and I really really
enjoyed it and I definitely recommend
this book if you were interested in
Japanese culture that's right I love
Japan whatever what are you gonna do sue
me that was it
thank you for watching that we did it
I'm loving these series I'm having so
much fun reading I know it sounds so
pretentious in a way almost but now for
the books that we're gonna read next
month I really want to read crime and
punishment a lot of people recommended
it from last month so I thought okay
yeah why not I also want to read stoner
I also want to read no longer human and
I think we should just start with those
three I don't want to overwhelm you guys
as well anyway thank you guys so much
for watching I really appreciate all the
support and all the fantastic comments
that I get on these videos it really
means a lot and I'll see you next month